allora allora siamo ritornati su human
forzato puntato in tempo perché hanno
aggiunto delle mappe nuove sono con
ciccio pietro e il liga preparatevi
perché la mappa è incredibile mezz'ora
allora qua c'è il cavo leverone stesso
sciogliendo il ghiaccio ma non ci veloci
non lo si chiama transitare solo
permesso che si scioglie permesso il
bilancio che ho sempre molto sentire lei
uno stolto si passa dalle balle ok ma
l'ho fatto sciogliere adesso ci passa
grande preso io prego la sinistra a
sinistra ma non ci riesco ok ok via e
adesso arriverà ecco il sicet una
boutade ma c'è stato qualcosa che poi
c'è un casino incredibile music hall e
luminoso ma cos'ha fatto
cos'ha fatto credibile ho fatto una cosa
incredibile ai vigili grai vista dimmi
che l'hai vista non dimmi che allora
riguardano riguarderà i questo video e
vedrai che cosa ho fatto fatto il salto
con l'asta è la madonna ragazzi potete
buttarvi giù avevo fatto sono state
livello in una maniera pazzesca amico
occhio ai a c'è il cartello del pericolo
non fa niente ok la madonnina negozio
tutto un centimetro di distanza 6 15 a
quello dopo incredibile stiamo andando a
velocità pazzesca in quelle ore che a
lei non spielber andare guarda questo te
lo devi co aiuto acqua video sacrificare
per voi questo nome ragazze a marco si
guardi a faccia lei lascia lei ace non è
bravo e altro modo perché siamo sempre
gli ultimi
parla per te lo è solo l'ultimo
spettacolo diversamente da mente
atterrare qua perfetto ce l'ho fatta
savings ragazzi ma se il ghiaccio li
usiamo quello facciamo prima aiuti
meloni aiuta si scioglie veloce e veloci
veloci
chiamai d'aiuto le logiche di ciò limiti
all'ombra vanti dall'ombra e croissants
e venite non è non è non venite voi qua
sopra
che devo fare il peso a pietro ma lei a
quelle sue parate che è accaduto che fin
dai aggrappati molla ciccio un casino
vai su qualcuno sara gama siete quanti
problemi ma ok poi la plage lascia e
vieni qua pietro
voglio fare quello che mi viene più ti
del contrappeso brava ok giorno fa ma
ragazzini come gino leone cammino un
cane
vorrei vedere un calo del prezzo quello
che ha fatto 60 punti buttati dusiburg
bellissima partita comunque apprezzo
chiusa vedova non ho questa cosa e
bellissima ragazzi vi prego venite tutti
aspetto questa voglio farlo ha potuto
arrivo arrivo arrivo io arrivai come si
fa però secondo lei io lo voglio così
vite sopra e al mio via ci mettiamo
tutti quanti ma non li mio pensano a 65
mai un malato atti aiuto dice un acero
in faccia che male che male abbiamo
fatto in due e cc è morto da solo io lo
so io lo sapevo
cc e molto la solita in due sinistra
sinistra sinistra esatto ma è
sacrificatisi ma faccio il cane va hard
è freddissimo
ok aspetti aspetti per il ritiro suzuki
non sappiamo vado io a pochi passi addio
dormi dirti il team che è certo è che ci
provo l'avrei lasciato tantissimo vieni
vieni ciccio tiliqua 18 è morto il cane
bastonato a me si può abbassare esatto
qua qua non basta saltare signora doveva
qualcosa io che faccio mi ha detto
saving ma perché forse abbiamo pagato la
parte forse sarebbe il caso per rompere
qui no
non so che qui le ragazze ci penso io
pago che servano segnalante qua non c'è
nulla se non nulle stone age questa roba
qua comunque mi butto giù mi vedesse
mandato il sailing suo è bisignano per
questo cuore anche se vai via che male
ai voti no
bisognano per lavoratori ci siamo recati
in volo così dobbiamo rompere quel
magico altronde anche non dove non c'è
più il tronco ragazzi non è il tronco
aspettiamo a insieme un ariete ha
sfondato lega ha fatto rumore strano che
io non so perché non ho l'audi è 3 a e 3
venite qua tutti o che ancora ora ve ne
serve di roccia ma come ancora una casa
ristrutturando un bagno che tesseva
roccia e dovrei buttare giù il muro
bravo ciccio con la roccia questa volta
ma no ma stia fermo ma lei è falso lì mi
tocca i momenti e bravi che ci circonda
polonia di marchionne tronca andava bene
la roccia no è solo di loro c'è da
penetrare o contrario e succede qua c'è
uno slittino ma prende fuoco ma quando
dovete portare quello sentitamente
ragione questo portiamo a vero portiamo
qua lo slittino aspetti che faccia
salire e poi a lei sale
ma dai ok spostare da miramare csc
ghiaccio che ti impedisce la strada ok
sposta facendo un giro un po strano però
ci arriva dalla sicuro
ecco a lei prego ecco posto ma non
doveva andare così se no ma non d'olanda
ragazzi e ora mi si rompano e adesso
spostiamo questo servire da piattaforma
ci serviva fa niente
lo show llano no non è vero questo qui
serviva ad aprire il buco perché adesso
abbiamo la luce per sciogliere che cosa
sciogliamo lo so e che ne so la cenal
evacua dall'altra leva generale va sotto
il ghiaccio averlo c'è del ghiaccio qua
qua sotto progetto qualcosa tanto il
ghiaccio c'è qualcosa dentro ghiaccio
quando dobbiamo sciogliere queste
ciccioli esistesse nord a un pezzo di
legno che servirà per rompere il
ghiaccio dalle va probabilmente sarà
esatto pensi che non commettono
etichetta ragazzi e ragazze ragazzi ma
sì ma qui ma si fidino assistere a posto
calcio sciolto abbiamo un pezzo di legno
in tutto questo cosa serva la pistola
non si spacca al deficit deve accendere
il fuoco
mi scusi mischia ho capito niente di
incidere piccola ho fatto ma era data
fuoco pietro scusi eccolo dunque
animazione tanti auguri con quale fisica
poi vada vada tra prego apra non si apre
ok a posto
ancorato sciistico molto dura ma tenga
in galline un bellissimo non aspetta
aiuto ma bisogna tenere preferito aiuto
aspetti vengo io ma no
malati che quel casino appello il
cappello di qua ragazzi no rimane teso
per alimenti sopra che può paesino
rimanete sui rivali dietro sacrificati e
butta giù dalle cose e cosa c'è una
scatola serve sicuro e cosa no no ma
volendo c'è un premio per far permettere
il ghiaccio li passando dall ombra tanto
abbiamo quindi abbia fatto e cosa stai
facendo esplodere mentre fatto chiesto
aiuto a posto a posto se arriva tempo di
creare dopo mi sa che costa un sacco
quelli all anno fa non ditemi che avete
il saving teoricamente dovremmo quasi
avere saving spetti gay ce l'ho ce l'ho
io potrei essere caduto ma io sono con
voi
per questo io sono rosi di sopra si
vinca abbiamo il civil qui sopra volete
pure venire in sì sì però io sono con
sopra per avermi un'arma il finale è
quello ma se sicuri al cento per cento
che ne sa lei cosa fa scommetto un
miliardo di euro ci sta
va bene come amico e miliardo di euro
signor gatto non avevo tutto incredibile
bravissimi sono orgoglioso di voi
gran partita bravissimi molto bene ma no
questo è a questa lobby questo livello
se a prof
bravi ragazzi i ragazzi che sarà la
prima delle due mappe nuove di human
flette faremo anche la prossima nel
prossimo episodio fateci sapere se vi è
piaciuto lasciato mi piace un commento e
iscrivetevi al cern è out e rimane
ragiona di centimetri escono che
spiacente anche la campanellina decidere
molto importante bene come sempre ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo vi do bella
ragazza
[Musica]